Batman super powered sunlight and
multiversal hijinks The Flash sprinted
through some plot points fast enough for
viewers to get left in the dust here are
the explanations you might have missed
for those confusing moments
the theatrical version of Justice League
which is considered to be dceu Canon by
Warner Brothers is set in 2017. it's a
general assumption that dceu movies are
set in the year they're released
therefore the flash takes place in 2023
most members of The League have made
separate appearances in other dceu media
in the time since the 2017 Teemo movie
many of which were without the actual
actors reprising their roles while the
league appeared in the finale of
Peacemaker only Ezra Miller and Jason
Momoa returned with the other characters
obscured in Shadows
[Music]
a tie in three-issue comic series titled
The Flash fastest man alive was released
in 2022 to bridge the gap between 2017's
Justice League and 2023's the Flash the
series follows Barry as he struggles to
balance his life as a solo superhero in
Central City and his job at the ccpd
crime lab occasionally receiving
mentorship and assistance from Batman
while phasing through solid matter is
one of Flash's many powers in the comic
books it was never established in the
dceu movies until the flash in the film
bear uses his phasing ability to
infiltrate rooms Dodge projectiles and
steal some beer from his neighbors when
primary carrying youngberry infiltrates
the Central City Police Department by
phasing through a door a microscopic
zoom in shows how his molecules vibrate
to pass through the molecules of the
door while the flash never explains how
Barry received this new power in the
second issue of the tie-in comic book
prequel The Flash the fastest man alive
Barry finds his entire body
uncontrollably vibrating during a fight
against tarpit after a bit of trial and
error with his new peculiarity Barry
discovers that if he maintains his
vibrative State whilst interacting with
objects he's able to phase through solid
objects
it's very common now for comic book
characters to wear new suits in each
Franchise entry without any explanation
as to how they got their upgrades in
Justice League flashed on a makeshift
suit of several heat resistant pieces
bolted Together made from the same
material used on space shuttles any
other material would burn from the
friction caused by Barry Speed in the
flash Barry Sports a new more
sophisticated and sleeker version of his
suit which includes a retractable visor
to protect his eyes and a Fitbit like
monitor that tracks Barry's nutrition
levels plus the whole costume fits into
a ring that Barry wears when not in use
this massive upgrade was subsidized by
Bruce Wayne the origin of the new suit
is shown in the first issue of The Flash
the fastest man alive tie-in comic where
flash faces off against girder who
damages the former's old suit Bruce
gives the dejected Berry a new suit
along with a note of encouragement
the flash devotes a major part of its
run time to primary trying to get
youngberry his powers
since primary originally thinks that he
stuck in the past he needs to power up
youngberry in order to keep the
canonical flow of events intact
including the incident in his own life
where he gets his powers
this becomes important because if
youngberry doesn't get his powers when
primary does then it would render
primary powerless and hence his act of
altering his mother's death would be
null and void however primary wasn't
stuck in the past he was stuck in an
alternate timeline and universe where
Barry getting his powers wouldn't have
any bearing on primary's future but
primary had no way of knowing this when
he attempted to get his younger self
access to the speed force
in the flash the older Bruce Wayne
dispels primary's perception about
branching timelines he explains the
changing a moment in history doesn't
just alter what happens after it but the
entire timeline itself including the
events before leading to the unintended
creation of an entirely different
universe
the moment in time when Barry saves his
mother acts as the fulcrum between his
universe and the alternate universe he
ends up in given that this version of
Bruce seemingly hasn't interacted with
any metahumans before it's worth
wondering how he's able to articulate
the concept of the Multiverse so well
using spaghetti strings the most
plausible answer to this is that Bruce
is smart enough to have theoretical
knowledge about the Multiverse among
various other topics
Batman seems to be the only hero in his
alternate universe he becomes Prime
Barry's last resort after failing to
find the other members of the Justice
League including cyborg Wonder Woman
Aquaman and Superman when we first see
the Caped Crusader he has a ragged
appearance and is older and retired
yeah
I'm Batman
while the film doesn't reveal anything
about what Batman had been up to in the
year since his retirement The Flash
director Annie musketti talked with real
blend about it saying there was a lot to
talk about where do we find Bruce Wayne
30 years after we saw him for the last
time I wanted to find Bruce in a place
where people do not expect to find him
so basically like a Batman that quit
some years ago for a reason that you
won't see in the movie but you're gonna
see it in the deleted scenes while Bruce
claims that he retired because he
finally managed to make Gotham City one
of the safest cities in the world
musketti further hinted at another
possible reason for Batman's seclusion
he said Bruce may have made the same
mistake as buried it in the flash by
using time travel to fix things it
likely didn't end well which caused The
Dark Knight to hang up his cape
permanently if that's the case it might
also answer the question of how Batman
already had a grasp on multiversal time
travel when he meets Barry
Kara zorrell was kept imprisoned and
malnourished for years potentially
decades when the two berries in Batman
find her she's too weak to even walk
however it only takes a sun bath for
Kara to recover as soon as she makes it
outside basking in the sunlight she
defeats the soldiers and saves her
Rescuers
viewers May wonder how Cara had healed
so quickly however Cara possesses the
same power that her cousin Superman has
the ability to use sunlight to heal
kryptonians are empowered by solar rays
emitted from Earth's sun Superman's
birth father Jarrell explains in Man of
Steel that it's why kryptonians possess
superhuman powers on Earth
why am I so different from them
a son that's younger and brighter than
dribbles
the healing power was first shown in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
Superman fighting doomsday in space is
weakened by a nuclear explosion launched
by the US government but recovers
quickly after some direct exposure to
sunlight
at one point in the movie A
demonic-looking Speedster shows up in
the speed force and pushes Barry into an
alternate 2013. at first glance flash
fans might recognize this mystery
character as dark flash who in the
comics is an evil version of Barry's
nephew and fellow flash Wally West from
the future
towards the end of the film it is
revealed that this darker version of
flash is actually young Barry himself
from the future whose blind obsession
with preventing the deaths of Batman and
Supergirl at the hands of Zod led him to
spend decades going back in time over
and over again at the cost of his own
sanity and physical health his body is
wrapped in Kryptonian blade stabbed into
him by Zod and his Kryptonian soldiers
each blade indicating the number of
failed attempts to fix the Theta deaths
of Batman and Supergirl dark flash
reveals that he pushed primary into the
alternate 2013 to send off a chain of
events that leads to this version of
Barry getting his powers and eventually
becoming dark Flash the character
becomes a cautionary tale for youngberry
who was horrified by how much his
obsession has overtaken his mind
youngberry's sacrifices himself to save
primary from his Sinister future self
and by extension erases Dart Flash from
existence
in nearly every version of The Flash the
death of Nora Allen is a major part of
Barry Allen's backstory it influences
his heroism and defines his relationship
with his father Henry given that
everyone but Barry believes that Henry
killed Nora in 2023's the flash Nora's
murder and Henry's resulting
imprisonment motivate Barry to go back
in time save both his parents and in
turn face the consequences of his
actions but the film leaves one big
question unresolved who really killed
Nora in the comics and the CW Show the
murderer is revealed to be the reverse
flash eobard Thon who neither appears
nor is mentioned in the flash which
makes sense as the movie is already
crowded enough with multiple characters
and subplots
director Andy musketti hinted at a
possible story for a sequel with Thon as
the main villain musketti told the
playlist well reverse flashes the
elephant in the room right it feels like
you can't make another movie without
addressing the one that in all accounts
is the murderer of Barry's mom so it
feels like the big villain went on to
name drop other possible villains for
the sequel I have my own favorites but
that's another story I'd like to see the
turtle at some point the slowest man on
Earth Gorilla Grodd of course and many
more
but it became clear that Michael
Keaton's Batman would be a key part of
the multiversal adventure of The Flash
fans began theorizing about other cameos
from previous DC films and TV shows and
indeed the film features numerous cameos
and homages to Heroes that came before
youngberry's obsessive time-altering in
his doomed attempts to save Batman and
Supergirl leads to a multiversal
collision which demands that he go back
and undo what started it all saving his
mother the sequence in the speed force
features Christopher Reeve Superman from
the
1978-1987 Superman movies joined by
Helen Slater's Supergirl from 1984
Supergirl both of whom had been
established to be in the same universe
but never crossed over given the poor
reception of Supergirl George Reeves as
Superman from the 1950s Adventures of
Superman series and Adam West's Batman
from the 1960s Batman TV show also
appear the Golden Age Flash Jay Garrick
makes an appearance during the sequence
although he is not portrayed by The
Flash actor Teddy Sears as was
previously thought it was confirmed by
TV line that the film just shows
Garrick's likeness and he was not
portrayed by any actor of note most
surprisingly Nicholas Cage appears in a
cameo as Superman finally appearing as
the man of steel after getting cast in
Tim Burton's unproduced 90s film
Superman lives
the sequence also features the laughs of
the Joker played by Cesar Romero and
Jack Nicholson through archival footage
new DC Studios co-heads James Gunn and
Peter Safran have big plans to reboot
the dceu as the DCU and one of the
projects on their proposed slate is
Batman the Brave and the Bold to be
directed by The Flash director Andy
musketti the announcement had fans
guessing who would play Batman in the
DCU audiences were more confused than
surprised to see George Clooney as Bruce
Wayne in the reset timeline at the end
of The Flash a consequence of Barry
altering the timeline once again to
strengthen his father's Alibi and prove
his innocence in Nora Allen's murder The
Cameo is clearly intended to be a
tongue-in-cheek joke as Barry's
disappointment at the site of Clooney's
Bruce Wayne is meant to mirror the
audience's reaction it's highly unlikely
the 62 year old actor would be returning
to be the de facto Batman of the new
universe given that Gunn had replaced
the now 40 year old Henry Cavill in
favor of a younger Superman for his
upcoming Superman Legacy there's also
the fact that Clooney's last appearance
as the caved Crusader wasn't exactly
well received by fans and critics in
fact Clooney has repeatedly apologized
for his portrayal of Batman in the years
since 1997's Batman and Robin
apologize to the crowd of Comic-Con for
Batman and Robin I always apologize
the future of the dceu's Barry Allen is
definitely unclear given the various
legal issues and alleged criminal
behavior of The Flash star Ezra Miller
there had been a point where the
severity of such reports had thrown the
fate of the 200 million dollar movie in
uncertainty given that Miller is
essentially the face of the film and it
would be difficult to Market it in light
of its star's highly publicized erratic
Behavior The Flash could actually have
ended up with the same fate as the
Batgirl movie which was shelved in 2022
as a result of poor response to test
screenings and a change in DC films as a
release strategy while many fans had
called for Miller to be replaced
director Annie musketti revealed that
the actor wouldn't be recast for a
possible sequel all that said with the
DC film Universe set to reboot under
Gunn and saffron only two films from the
old dceu regime are left to be released
Blue Beetle and Aquaman the lost kingdom
Gunn retroactively deemed one of those
Blue Beetle canon in his upcoming DCU
though the flash was anticipated to be
Ben Affleck's final outing as Batman the
actor had reportedly also shot some
scenes for Aquaman the lost kingdom
during the films reshoots presumably
just in case the Batman situation wasn't
confusing enough for fans
foreign